when I communicate science with someone
who doesn't have background expertise
they're not dumber than me you know this
idea that we said we are dumbing down in
order for people to understand they're
not dumber than me they just haven't had
the benefit of years of dedicated
thinking about this stuff that I have
getting an idea across in a way that I
think they can understand sure I'm going
to probably leaving out some of the
details of the algebraic derivation that
are not important in getting the concept
across but it gives me genuine pleasure
to see that penny drop like bulb come oh
oh I see now I get the same sort of
tingle or enjoyment of someone
understanding something that I've
explain that I got when I first learned
that today you are all in for a treat as
we speak to Professor Jim ALC who is a
fellow of the Royal Society a Quantum
physicist and holder of the University
of Sur distinguished chair as well as a
personal chair in physics how many
chairs can you have you got a university
chair a personal chair and the public
engagement
I've got a whole three-piece Suite I say
you're like a oneman Ikea exactly
exactly I am uh going to try to be
mindful of your time because I know uh
it's very gracious of you to spend any
time here but we have a new book that's
coming out called the joy of science so
I want to start off by doing what you're
told never to do in life which is to
judge a book by its cover so Jim tell me
what is the origin of this book's title
subtitle and the the awesome cover
design as well I had all all a whole
list of different titles that I had
suggested to my Publishers Princeton
University press and it was about you
know rationalism the scientific method
and none of them really sort of
resonated or sort of captur the
imagination and then my editor at
Princeton suggested the joy of science
because I mean it is a celebration of
why science is so important why we
scientists do what we do how it gives us
a better understanding and empowerment
because we can understand more about how
the world is you know Enlightenment over
ignorance but it's also a book about how
we do science the scientific method and
the fact that if we could use some of
the techniques that we use in science
when science is done properly in daily
life I think it would make everyone you
know the happier you know the idea of
you know the importance of doubt and
uncertainty the importance of examining
your evidence being prepared to change
your mind so it was eight lessons from
the scientific method so that's one of
the reasons why you have sort of the
letter eight two circles on on on the
cover and the other is the at the very
beginning I use an example I'm not the
first auor to do this you know people
like um Carl San certainly use it
talking about the the the beauty of the
rainbow and why you know when the poet
Keat criticizes Newton by saying you
know you've you've destroyed that
exactly exactly you know the the the
breaking light into its Prismatic colors
some weaving the rainbow and weaving
yeah and and you destroy the Beauty and
the Poetry of it and rubbish you know
the fan talks about this very eloquently
it doesn't it adds it adds to the beauty
so there there's the colors of the
rainbow there on on the on the book as
well yeah I found that quite lovely the
book is a delight it's a quick read I
actually because I don't think it's
available yet on audiobook format I
actually put it into an app called
speechify uh and I listened to a British
accent voice and it was really
delightful uh this book can be consumed
with delight in just a few hours and yes
those characters speak vividly through
the book as well as some of their maybe
counterpoints and and maybe I want to
start with the battle epic battle
between Walt Witman and and Richard
feineman you know the Learned astronomer
versus the Learned physicist and and of
course Fineman as you quote says you
know do I care less about Jupiter
because I know he's not a God and made
of meth no so I taught a class here with
a Pitzer Prize winner by the name of Ray
Arman trout who's a poet and uh we
taught a class called uh called poetry
for physicists which is the exact
opposite of what you normally teach but
I wonder how much uh can we learn from
our poetic friends as as your Countryman
uh Paul D said you know uh something
like you know poets attempt to do
explain the most simple things in the
most obtuse obfuscation language
possible and in science the joy is doing
just the opposite so so explain that
tension that fundamental tension um yeah
I mean I don't see that tension I I I
start off in the book and saying uh
first of all science isn't a collection
of facts that's called knowledge science
is the process by which we acquire that
knowledge by also acknowledge that there
are other ways that we gain knowledge
Enlightenment wisdom we know and it
could be through poetry or art or
literature or music or contemplation or
or religious texts or just discussing
and debating with our fellow human
beings science is one way and when it
comes to the the the the the the the
Natural Sciences you know our area
physics for example science I believe is
the most reliable way of getting
to understand the nature of of of of
physical reality out there poetry is a
is a is a tool that can bring that to
life can add to the narrative to add to
the story of how the way the world is I
don't think poetry detracts from our
ability to understand I think it
enriches in the way that science also
enriches out understand so different
different ways of looking at the world
yeah hopefully they can complement each
other and absolutely lead to some uh
some further um you know Warfare um so
you mentioned you know knowledge and of
course you know the word science in
Latin mean Siena means uh means
knowledge but it doesn't mean wisdom
that's what Sapient or Sapienza means so
you know do you think at some level
enough uh knowledge can kind of convert
you to to having wisdom in other words
is there is there a quantity after which
you assume such amount of quantity of
knowledge that you actually become wise
are they fundamentally blocked off from
one another I don't think they're the
same thing I mean that that they are
connected with each other the more
knowledge and experience you have I
would suggest they're correlated you
should be more rather than less wise but
I don't think wisdom is something that
can be acquired if if you know someone
who knows nothing about a particular
area or discipline if they could absorb
all the knowledge and information about
that discipline that doesn't make them
wise I like the the fact that for me at
my stage in my in my career I'm now
leaning more towards offering wisdom to
my my young students rather than you
know the knowledge they're smarter
they're faster than me they can remember
stuff I've forgotten more than they've
learned but I hope that I can offer
wisdom and I don't think that's the same
thing as because I have an accumulation
of knowledge but they are connected they
are connected yeah what do you how do
you react to this statement I'm going to
I'm going to drop on you follow the
science what does that mean to you oh
God yeah it it's it's it's the the
phrase that has been used by politicians
particularly during the pandemic over
the last two years to somehow absolve
themselves of any responsibility you
know if they don't follow sensible
policies just to say we are following
the sign it's meaningless I mean you you
say we are following the advice of
scientists uh uh based on our current
understanding fine but I I if that's
what they mean and they've just
shortened it down to follow the science
three words fine but I worry that
politicians don't actually understand
what the science you know following the
science means doing doing science means
following the scientific method you're
not doing that you're listening to
someone giving you advice which chances
are you going to ignore in your opinion
uh you know I always get kind of um
reaction to this you know that there is
no real one scientific method I mean you
don't go down and you know I don't go
down to my laboratory and say now I'm
going to test the hypothesis and then
I'm going to acquire uh and and actually
there in my estimation I mean you're
you're you know far better qualified to
answer but there's multiple scientific
methods there's deductive there's
inductive um what is this what is the
scientific method is it just a rubric is
it just a shorthand or is it a shth what
is it exactly I certainly think it's
it's it's a a a collection of all the
ways that we've used across the
disciplines that we call scientific
disciplines to gain more knowledge it's
certainly not a you know a tick a box
ticking exercise and say you know what
does it mean to be a scientist well you
have to be curious about the world well
you know a conspiracy theorist is
curious It's about Gathering evidence
and and well the conspiracy theorists
think they're being rational and
Gathering evidence and being skeptical
and so on is it about testing
hypothesis against you know you come up
with a narrative hypothesis test it
against observation well a historian
does that as well does that mean history
is part of science no it means they're
using the same techniques to learn
something about the nature of the past
as as opposed to the nature of physical
reality around us so there isn't a list
of things some areas of science require
you know falsifiability or repr
reproducibility and so on other areas
require testing of hypothesis and coming
up with a theory that has predictive
power but even you know having
predictive power is not enough you know
your your your your star signs you you
know reading your astrological star
chart may say you're going to get
promotion next Tuesday when you're going
to work and sure enough your boss gives
you promotion say oh look it predicted
correctly therefore astrology is a
science right you know there isn't one
size fits all it is a you're right it's
a nebulous term that can mean different
things depending on the sort of science
that we're doing my thumb is very busy
right now holding up good old Albert but
if yours is free please go ahead and hit
that like button and don't forget to
subscribe it really helps us with the
algorithm so last year past guest on the
show Lord Martin Reese told me you know
pertinent to Astron astrology that you
know he's responsible as the astronomer
Royal to tell the queen her horoscope I
thought that was really nice I'd like to
have that gig you know for the president
here I'd like to be the federal
astronomer uh but but in reality yeah
there there is as as we maybe pivot to a
subject that you you bring up in the joy
of science this of fascination with with
Carl popper and and this falsification
and you just pointed out you know uh not
only could such a prediction of a
soothsayer as poer called them come true
but it's also falsifiable if you didn't
get the Rays so then his hypothesis was
falsified therefore it's science what
gives I mean what what how much should
we put on popper I mean in my
understanding he didn't even think we
should put that much eff emphasis on
falsification as the sinuan nan no
absolutely I think when I was a student
um it was always argued that you know
that the two the great philosophers of
Science of our age were KL popper and
Thomas you know the the Paradigm
Shift ideas I think these days this
notion the Poppa's idea of falsification
isn't held at in such high regarding
know put on a pedestal like it used to
you know we we're much more careful now
talking about you know being good basian
you know that having you know prior you
know that what's the probability that
this idea is right well based on what
your initial assumptions were surely and
what's the probability that they were
right the idea of falsification I i' use
the example in the in the book which is
many people have used before you know
all swans are white you see one one
brown Swan and and you say see that
suggests that you know it falsifies your
theory that all swans are white but then
how do you know that brown Swan isn't
just a white swan caked in
mud so that the the the falsifying
counter example itself may not be
correct you know we've seen this in
physics you know you the the famous
experiment of the faster than light
neutrinos a few years ago that oh yes
Opera yeah they oper Opera experiment
you know they they detected these
particles that looked like they were
getting from A to B fast in the speed of
light oh Einstein's wrong you know and
then but it turns out the experiment
itself was wrong there was a loose cable
behind one of the the counters and the
computers so that's right just having
one false so yeah so falsification is is
uh probably not not as as a strong a
definition of what good a good science
ific Theory should be and then uh you
mentioned you know a frequent character
in all popular books in addition to
Fineman and and uh and Galileo and
Newton you mentioned Einstein just a
second ago and chapter uh chapter five
in this wonderful book is called uh
entitled don't value opinion over
evidence and I wonder if we could talk
about Authority and my favorite
scientist of all time is Galileo who
said uh in matters of science the uh you
know the issues of authority cannot uh
overcome the humble reasoning of a of a
lone individual of course I get that all
the time yesterday alone I mean I posted
on my Twitter you know I'm gonna be
talking to you and uh I got all sorts of
like people want me to ask you about
their theories about you know conscious
electrons and this thing and and we'll
get to some audience questions don't
don't worry because that that is part of
my Hallmark on this channel uh but
nevertheless you should also have some
respect for authority in science as as
Fineman or Sean I can never remember
which one said um you know I'd rather
have you know answers uh that questions
that cannot be answered then answers
that cannot be questioned to me that's a
Canard against you know religion but I
wonder you know do we worship you know
this guy a little bit over much uh are
we kind of infatuated in fact in the
public when we see things like the
during the Corona virus that you just
mentioned or with the Iran nuclear deal
they Trot out 70 Nobel Prize winners you
know 11 of whom have been on my show you
know and and they'll just Trot them out
and then we're supposed to say okay
we'll just do what you say in all these
matters even though you're a condensed
manner physicist talking about a vaccine
that's you know m&n anyway to what level
should the general lay person experience
a little bit of the joy of Science by
questioning the authorities even this
guy first of all having is something we
see on social media more and more these
days you know valuing opinion over
evidence is is a is a worry uh and it's
true that you know you know when my my
plumber comes around to fix my boiler
and he says I know what's wrong with it
uh you know there's this error it's it
means you got to change this the circuit
board I don't say to him don't worry you
know I've had a look on YouTube and I
know exactly what I can do it myself or
I'm a theoretical physicist I'm a
theoretical physicist I everything is
made of quarks surely I must I must be
able to for I know so much more than you
could have um no Lenny sukin was a
plumber so oh right right okay so yeah
so he can do that he can say that but
the rest of us no so to some extent you
have to say look someone has expertise
because they've had years of study and
and thinking about this and you can't
just come to it and say what right does
this person have to say that they're
right and I'm wrong U you know I I I'm
sure you get the same as me we get the
emails and the letters from people
saying I have no background in physics
however you know I've proven Einstein
wrong you know e equal MC cubed you know
not MC squar and if you help me I'll
share the Nobel Prize with you yeah but
I'm not telling you yet because you know
that's right you have to help me get my
my stuff up think oh so you know you
don't want to insult people some some of
these these people are very Earnest and
and and genuine and they've spent years
thinking about this stuff but they
haven't had the benefit of of you know
doing a proper course on in physics for
example relativity Theory and in all
likelihood you know you you have to tell
them look just because I no one believed
Einstein when he came along you know and
and he changed the you know that caused
the Paradigm Shift doesn't mean that you
are also another Einstein with all due
respect doesn't hold right yeah with all
due respect you know that he was one of
a kind but you're right the the flip
side is that we overly respect someone
because they have a title or because you
know they they they they they are have
expertise in one area and we assume if
it has the whiff of science then it must
be true I I mean in the commercial World
in businesses this is how they advertise
stuff you know you you know add a new
yogurt or a new face cream you add a
scientific word there oh wow see
scientists have said you know and
therefore it becomes the truth so we do
have to
question where the evidence comes
chances are if someone's dedicated their
life to a subject then I would give them
the benefit of the doubt I wouldn't
assume that I shouldn't trust anything
they say because they may have alter
alterior motives they may have alterior
motives they may you know may be saying
something because their pay masters want
them to or because they want to promote
a particular Theory because they've
invested their lives in it even though
it's wrong but there's a good chance CH
that if you're an expert you probably
know more than someone who just comes up
with some opinion do you think you can
you know turn someone into a scientist
you know just based on their pure
passion like you said curiosity you know
my uh curious about conspiracies myself
sometime we'll get to those later in the
next interview but uh can you really
convert you know teach someone to be a
scientist can you can you start and and
if so how how how would you how do you
do well well yeah absolutely you can I
mean being a scientist these we are not
a separate species from the rest of
humankind you know we are people who you
know we're all curious as children and
we ask the why questions most people as
they grow up they you know they they got
to get on with their lives they got to
get a job and a mortgage and a family
and all the you know the challenges of
daily life and they stop asking those
why questions they stop being curious
about how and why is the world the way
it is they don't have that luxury those
of us who are trained in science it
becomes our job to keep asking those
questions so we remain curious but
training someone to become a scientist
is not is nothing special it's about
showing how we do science it's about you
know the scientific method being you
know one of the most important things
are never being completely certain about
something always allowing T place for
doubts to change your mind and also
being prepared to admit when you're
wrong you know and I always said that's
the difference between a good scientific
theory and a conspiracy theory ask a
conspiracy theorist what evidence would
it take for me to persuade you to change
your mind and they would have to admit
nothing nothing would by definition a
conspiracy theorist it's it's that's
their whole reason for beli what they
believe because nothing is going to
disuade them whereas a scientist a good
scientist has to be prepared to say I
was wrong I thought this Theory this
hypothesis this I could explain this
phenomenon you've presented me with data
uh or some observational evidence that
suggests I'm wrong I had to change my
mind not all scientists not all
scientists do that right not all
scientists are good but that's the way
it should work and I don't see any
reason why anyone couldn't learn to to
to think in that way now when you hear
things like trust the science I want to
Pivot now to uh actually what I
understand is the impetus for writing
the book you know came out of the covid
pandemic you know Co came out I recall
things in the UK uh Professor Ferguson
the Rival institution and other coming
out with uh models predicting dire you
know numbers of deaths uh you know in
very short period of time and eventually
maybe that'll prove to be correct and
and similarly you mentioned global
climate change and global warming a lot
of this is based on extremely complex
physics uh and if at all if it is linear
if we can actually be reductionist and
and say that well a virus is just
biology biology is just chemistry
chemistry is just cell you know physics
etc etc uh at some level physicist
should be able to do stuff and yet we
get a lot of things wrong uh when we
turn turn to models talk about like what
is the role of a model model in science
and and and not the runway kind of which
you certainly could be one of the guests
I I'd have the a radio show on on the
BBC the the life scientific which uh
which has been going for many years and
which I interview um other other
scientists I remember interviewing a
climatologist Tam in Edwards very smart
scientist who you know works on
mathematical models and she has a
website and a Blog which has the title
all models are wrong I forget who where
the quote comes from all models are
wrong but some are more useful than
others right or something like that so a
model is a model it it makes a
prediction and it's only as good as
whatever information you feed it in the
first place we try and develop our
models to make them more more
sophisticated We Trust models more if
you have two very different
computational models to different sort
of imaginary pictures of of reality that
make the same predictions if they come
at some you know prediction about how
something will change and evolve like
how the what the climate would look like
50 years from now and they have
different assumptions and inputs and yet
both point to the same thing happening
tends to make them it's a bit like doing
two different experiments in two
different labs and they both discover
the same phenomenon the that
reproducibility so so a computer a
computational model is a is a is like
doing an experiment in the lab but with
zeros and ones uh and you can get it
wrong in the same way that you can get
your experiment wrong so so models are
useful but we shouldn't
we shouldn't trust that they are telling
us the truth but at the same time we
shouldn't dismiss them out of hand
simply
because one day they we might find that
they're incomplete and I think that's
all well and good when you're looking at
you know the Millennium simulation of
structure formation in the early
universe or you're looking at you know
how uh certain you know primates you
know evolved and got out of Africa but
you know the other hand when it impacts
you know the lay person in their daily
life things like climate change things
like viral you know epidemiology yeah uh
if you can't trust these people who as
you say rightfully so have dedicated
their lives to this career I mean what
does it do to the scientific confidence
people have confidence in science when
they will if anything know when people
get models wrong rather than right yeah
I think for one thing is people need to
understand how science works I that's
something has happened to some extent
over the course of the last two years of
the pandemic people have seen the
scientific method in action and I've
seen these modelers saying this is going
to happen or you know the way to stop
yourselves from Catching Co is to you
know to wash your hands I know if this
was the same thing in the US but in the
UK it was there was the Mantra wash your
hands while singing Happy Birthday twice
through right you that that length of
time you know and then you know a few
months later it was oh no no washing
your hands isn't so important you got to
wear a mask or you got to have
ventilation and so so people who don't
understand how science Works said hang
on you guys just told told me that I
could avoid catching Co washing my hands
now you're saying I got to wear a mask
you know nothing but if people
understand how science Works say well no
this is in the light of new evidence we
need to be able to backrack to change
our minds to you know to to revise our
view what also is important particularly
for something like climate change I
think is that we have to apply the
precautionary principle that we know
we're never going to be sure that you
know the climate is going to change in
this way or or that it's going to lead
to these dire consequences
but in all likelihood it's you know
there's the the famous example that you
know 97% of climatologists say you know
we humans are changing the climate there
must have been some survey some years
ago 97% of you know and and then people
say well hang on a minute so you're not
sure so there's 3% of good Scientists
who argue the difference maybe you're
wrong but if you go to your doctor and
and your doctor says if you don't give
up drinking and smoking and change your
diet you know you're going to be dead in
five years and you say well doctor how
sure are you well I can't be sure I'd
say 97% sure you're not going to turn
around and say ah okay I'm going to seek
a second opinion because you're not sure
you adopt the precautionary principle
and say chances are you're right better
safe than sorry we should do something
about it so and that's how I feel about
climate change chances are things are
going going badly wrong and we need to
do something about it maybe we we don't
have to but we can't afford not to do
something yeah one of the powerful
takeaways you know from the book and
from you know convers a I've heard on
the life scientific and elsewhere is
that um you know when you say something
when a scientist says I don't know it it
doesn't mean like everything's equally
likely you know it doesn't mean like I
don't know what's gonna happen with you
know doesn't mean like CO's nothing or
it's everything or GL and change and yet
again when it does impact you know the
ordinary person I feel like you and I
let's I just want to toot our own horns
for a second we get paid by the taxpayer
at some level to do a job we would do
for free I mean don't tell Gavin new but
I would do it for free right I don't
know about you but but I assume that you
would because you have so much joy
literally and that's the reason I think
you use that in the title right so it's
pleasurable we get paid so on what other
job you know if you if you are the
plumber and uh and you come over to fix
the house and the plumber tells you uh
you can't understand what I'm doing it's
very complicated and and she's right you
know she's actually very astute and
knows Plumbing she's done her dedicate
her whole life to Plumbing as you said
but yeah if she tells you you can't
understand it it's very complicated and
as you quote feeman saying in the book
you know if I could explain why I won
the Nobel Prize it wouldn't be worth a
Nobel Prize on the other on another day
he said if you don't if you can't
explain it to your grandmother you don't
understand like which is it finean you
know I wanna I want to ask but anyway uh
to what extent do you believe or maybe
disag I'll State what I believe I think
it's a moral obligation that we
scientists have and that we fail
miserably at half the time because we're
so busy but we have to tell the public
in terms they can understand what we're
doing with their money that they've
given us this treasure to do what we
would do for free what how how have you
UTI because you obviously are one of the
master communicators who've ever lived I
mean actually because of your huge
impact BBC and in America and Netflix
and all the places you've had an
outsized impact did you have training
what is your underlying philosophy of
doing that essential Outreach which is
to the benefit of science so we can keep
getting funds to do what we love I have
to say in all honesty I don't do my
science communication altruistically
because I feel I have a moral obligation
for the world to be more scientifically
literate I do it because it gives me joy
you know I I've always said that I don't
want just to be a science Communicator
talking about other other people doing
the science I want to be a scientist who
communicates but when I find out
something fascinating about the world
why why wouldn't I want to shout it from
the rooftops why wouldn't I want to tell
everyone about it when I communicate
science when I'm explaining something to
to to someone who doesn't have the the
the background expertise they're not
dumber than me you know this idea that
we said we are dumbing down in order for
people to understand that's nons they're
not they're not dumber than me they just
haven't had the benefit of years of
dedicated thinking about this stuff that
I have getting an an idea across in a
way that I think they can understand
sure I'm I'm I'm going to probably
leaving out I'll be leaving out some of
the details of the algebraic derivation
that are not important in getting the
concept across but it gives me genuine
pleasure to see that penny drop the
light bulb come oh oh I see now I get a
I get the same sort of tingle enjoyment
of someone understanding something I've
explained that I got when I first
learned that about that so so I I do my
science communication because I I enjoy
it personally although of course I
acknowledge you're right you know we
have a moral obligation not every
scientist is good at communicating
science some scientists in in in
Academia are better at research others
are better at teaching uh you know and
you know horses for courses but those
who can communicate those who are
who want to you know like like you and
me you know who want to sort of get
across these ideas and and and Empower
society and and infus absolutely we have
to do it because that's you know this is
not some this is not something that we
should be keep keeping to ourselves no
it's too much fun yeah it's magic that's
real right yeah right I want to ask you
what's the biggest source of hype right
now in physics or science in general
what what is the biggest perhaps most
overblown thing in science that's uh in
the category of hype I think it might be
when we we talk about the what uh the
opportunities with Quantum Technologies
and and Quantum Computing for example
the the impression that the public gets
is that quantum computers are going to
you know to to to replace our our
current computers and they can do
everything so much quicker and better
the same with with artificial
intelligence you know that that we are
years maybe decades but maybe only just
years away from art artificial general
intelligence and and and machines that
can become conscious that sort of hype I
can understand why because they're
exciting and you know Hollywood gets you
know makes a good living out of the
science fiction movies that based on
those themes but it does give people the
wrong impression that we're getting we
we're approaching this wonderful these
technologies that are that are probably
we're not going to see in our in our
lifetime all right in a few decades ago
there's a lot of hype in theoretical
physics that we were coming to the end
of theoretical physics you know that the
large hyron collider would discover all
sorts of new particles that we we you
know that we're approaching a theory of
everything and Steven hking wrote an
article about 40 years ago about you
know the end of theoretical physics just
got to dot the eyes cross the te's and
and no actually we're we're a long way
off we don't even know what dark matter
is made of so there was that hype I
think we've we've sort of sobered up a
bit from that we realized we have a long
way to go in understanding the nature of
reality but in the the technologies that
we that that are being promised now I
think there's a good deal of hype that's
uh that we should also try try and pull
back from funny that you mentioned it
because we did talk about that and it's
it's sort of like what I say about
String Theory you know string theory is
the best theory ever made to describe
the properties and possibilities of
string theory and like quantum computers
are really good as Fineman predicted at
like unraveling how quantum computers
work and how Lans work but uh in my
field you know cosmology we hear about
the Multiverse I even had on David
Cher's I talk about the simulation
hypothesis
are these things that um physicists use
to generate you know clicks and Eyeball
I certainly do that by the way I mean
this this episode will be called you
know J KH tells all in a way that he's
never told it
before Co free loving it co was a 5G
ruse no no I'm not gonna do that don't
worry but in reality you know we kind of
do you know there's a universe running
backwards in time I just saw in the
guardian last week you know to what
extent does that uh is that playful it's
in good fun or can it really detract
from from the public support they find
out like well didn't you guys claim
neutrinos travel faster than the speed
of light that appeared on page one of
the New York Times the retraction
appears on page you know B7 on the
weekend edition six months later so what
responsibility do we have I've said we
should have a PR budget I I'm fully
aware we should have a p but we should
have a retraction budget as well like
how how do you deal with the
self-correcting essence of science would
you touch upon so heavily in this book
science is self-correcting that's often
wrong never in doubt maybe but how do
how do we correct in a way that shows
the public that we're honest have
integrity but we also make mistakes it's
difficult when when it comes to subjects
that you know the the sexier parts of
science things like you know cosmology
or particle physics or advances in
genetics or artificial intelligence
because you know the the media and
journalists even if they're good science
journalists they want the headlines they
want the the clicks you know they they
want to infuse and they don't care if
you know as you say you know a month or
two down the line it turns out that that
was that was wrong you know it's too
late you know you've got people excited
in some respects I think it's good to
infuse the The Wider public with the
excitement of science you know it
happened back where the in 2008 when the
large hyron collider was turned on and
then the runup to it you know people say
oh you turn this partic acceler so much
energy you're going to create a black
hole that's going to swallow up the
Earth and a lot of my colleagues were
horrified by that that's that's just bad
science when get it's bad science but
you you got people in bars talking about
particle physics and you know but you
then have to follow it up right you you
have to you have to follow up to to make
sure that people's expectations of what
science is going to deliver are
realistic these are exciting things they
they're they're you know fizzing our
imagination but that doesn't necessarily
mean that you know they are correct
because you're right you know because
then if you know a few months down the
line say oh no no you know we we thought
there was a there there was inflation
and there isn't or we thought there were
parallel universes and you know what do
we believe so we've got to we've got to
explaining the the excitement and and
the the coolness of some of the science
that we do we also have to explain how
we do science part of that is to say
that look this is a hypothesis you know
we don't know we haven't tested it you
know string theory is very neat and
Powerful math but that doesn't mean that
you know there are 10 dimensions of
vibrating may may turn out to be wrong
is it science yes it's still science you
know cosmology and Multiverse even if
something isn't testable
doesn't mean it's it's metaphysics or
philosophy or theology it's still part
of science it's just we haven't figured
out how to test it yet right I'm more
optimistic in that way one day we might
be able to say whether string theory is
right or wrong but until then it's it's
it's it's nice maths yeah and if you say
something is settled science that to me
closes off the possibility that a young
right you know Alberta Einstein or you
know will come along and and solve this
great problem uh that you actually were
wrong about but you didn't know it
because you felt that's a much better
outcome you know we we didn't want the
higs bow on to be discovered right cuz
that would have meant new physics to be
oh okay it is it's there after all take
that box yeah I mean the
experimentalists wanted it to be there
oh yeah listen listen if you spent 20
years building a l the largest particle
accelerator in the world yeah you want
to find something and speaking of which
I'm gonna have Frank Clos on soon great
good mine yes yes he wrote a great new
book called elusive about Peter higs
kind of a bio of him signed ific but
also popular bio of him so one of the
delightful chapters that I I really
loved uh is entitled uh chapter seven is
entitled don't be afraid to change your
mind I want to ask you Jim what have you
changed your mind about in my area of
research so I started off I don't work
so much in nuclear reaction Theory now
but I started my PhD was in into
studying modeling nuclear reactions I
remember was looking at particular type
of atomic nucleus and how the protons
and neutrons are arranged and I had
developed a model to to calculate
cross-section so the chances that a
particle hitting another was going to
bounce off at a certain angle and I
developed a model published papers on it
and then realized that what I was doing
wasn't wasn't the complete picture and I
remember having a a running battle with
a rival group of researchers and we'd
like stand up in conferences and no no
you know you you know I can ask this
question why and I think both of us
realized that the other guy was also
right and that somehow we had to find a
compromise um and so so you know you you
do that in science you you you have a
view an idea or you develop a theory you
publish papers you have to be prepared
you know to admit at some point that
that is not you know the end of the
story that you may have an incomplete
picture I don't like admitting this but
I I hated the many worlds interpretation
the Everest interpretation of of of
quantum mechanics one of the ways of
explaining you know what is going on in
the quantum world I Blame You know
people like Shan Caroll because they are
so so persuasive yeah but but I I have
to admit that I'm sort of thinking yeah
it's it is quite appealing it I I'm I'm
not as against many worlds as I used to
be and I'm I'm saying this publicly now
maybe for the first time so I so I may
live to
regret my words but yeah you have you
have to be prepared that's you know
that's what science is about it's not
about holding on to to to a cherished
idea or view or ideology that's why it's
different from politics or religion or
you know science it's it's about the way
the world is and if someone tells you
it's not the way you thought it was you
have to accept that so we're coming
close to the end of your allotted time
and I have a few more questions for
myself that I'll will wrap up with but I
want to answer at least a few audience
questions and we're starting with one
from a uh young very shy very unknown
Scientist by the name of Sabina Hassen
Felder who endorsed your book your
lovely book Blair belong with she's a
past guest and upcoming guest for her
new book and then uh my best one of my
best friends uh Sylvester James Gates
Brown University blurbed it as well but
subina asked the following question
what's the most exciting area of physics
so it's kind of the the Contra pass to
the to the what's the biggest hype she
wants to know what do you think is the
most exciting area of physics or or
science it could be all of science well
it depends the most exciting area for me
or the most exciting area that I think
other people think is for you for me
well for me I mean I you know when when
people look for a theory of everything
we working in in qu quantum gravity
they're trying to unify two of the big
pictures in physics you know the quantum
mechanics that describes the world of
the very small and general relativity
describing the the world of the cosmic
scale and and as we know you know
they're struggling to find the correct
picture whether it's String Theory or
Loop quantum gravity or some other idea
for me what is exciting is unifying
quantum mechanics with another pillar of
physics which is
thermodynamics so for me the most
exciting thing is is a is is this new
new um area of of of quantum
thermodynamics in Quantum information
Theory Quantum thermodynamics the the uh
uh um far from equilibrium statistical
mechanics all those ideas to do with
things like the nature of time itself I
find is the most exciting you know where
does the aror of time come from where
does you know the irreversibility of
time come from when down at the quantum
world even and and indeed in the
Newtonian world the equations are
reversible in time so where does that
direction and time come from it exists
in thermodynamics it's it points in the
direction of increasing entropy
increasing disorder how does that link
in with Quantum so for me what's
exciting is trying to um blend together
mesh together quantum mechanics and
thermodynamics there are people who've
spent years thinking about this I'm sort
of coming to it quite green but I've
bought the textbooks I've started
reading the papers I've got a couple of
post dos working on it that's what's
giving me a buzz at the moment okay this
is a question from my YouTube channel so
remind you can ask questions of all my
guests on my YouTube channel which is Dr
Brian keing and this one is from
Nicholas Paulson it's a it's more of a
statement uh and he says don't miss the
book called the science of Joy by Jim's
brother Jim AAL AAL not alkal I didn't
know you had a brother name I I didn't
know nor did I know that he'd written a
book so similar and titled to mine and
he's an alkaline he's he's an acid
that's the
guy so last question from the audience
from my friend who goes by the moniker
memes of Destruction which I was
actually going to choose for one of my
kids names uh he says I keep hearing
about an anti- Universe might this or
some hidden phenomenon help explain the
similarity between gravity and
electromagnetism maybe this universe
that runs backwards in time could that
somehow explain the equational
Simplicity or similarity between
Maxwell's equations and Einstein's
equations it's difficult to say what is
the similarity between Maxwell's
equations is's equations other than the
fact that we can describe them both in
terms of fields you know we have a
gravitational field we have
electromagnetic field but the whole um
difficulty in finding a theory of of
quantum gravity is unifying uh Quantum
field Theory which encompasses the
electromagnetic force with general
tivity which is gravity so the problem
in modern physics is how gravity and
electromagnetism come together now
Einstein was working towards this but he
wasn't working he wasn't doing it at a
Quantum level you know the idea that uh
there were ideas back in the early 20th
century due to cusa and Klein suggesting
that um there is a connection between
gravity and electromagnetism and you
need another dimension to to bring them
together but the notion that an anti-
Universe I don't even know what an anti-
Universe means a universe made of
antimatter or is it Universe running
backwards in time they're interesting
ideas but I think it's that there are
too many Concepts that we're trying to
sort of put together logically here to
make any sense of well Jim we've reached
the regularly uh scheduled question
limit and now we're going to break here
going to create a separate video where
Jim is going to answer the thrilling
three patented thrilling three questions
about existential meaning and wisdom so
you'll have to subscribe to the channel
and over on my newsletter at Brian
king.com to get that I'll have links to
Jim's uh phenomenal output and all of
his tv specials and of course the life
scientific Jim thank you so much and
please stick around for few more minutes
of existential questions pleasure it's
been fun okay